only on CBS this morning we went behind
the scenes to see what the Apollo 11
crew did and the hours before they
blasted off for the moon 50 years ago
today treats what were they thinking
Tony shows us everything from where they
suited up to what they ate for breakfast
he's at the Kennedy Space Center where
the historic launch took place
Tony do tell hey good morning again guys
you should be seeing a countdown clock
on your screen right now that's a
countdown to the anniversary and it's
similar to the countdown that the
astronauts face 50 years ago today
Michael Collins Buzz Aldrin and Neil
Armstrong they woke up not far from
where I'm standing right now and they
woke up with that singular mission in
mind they were to become the first human
crew to land on the moon and not only
land but step out and actually walk on
another world
Bob Cabana former astronaut and the
director of the Kennedy Space Center
here guided us through the steps
Apollo's lunar pioneers took on that
special day on July 16 1969 at 4:15 a.m.
the astronauts would have woken up here
at astronaut crew quarters that would
have been in a bedroom just down this
hallway to the right and made their way
to the dining room we're on the menu
anything they wanted but what they
happen to choose with scrambled eggs
steak toast orange juice and coffee how
are they thinking about that flight to
come I think they're thinking you've
practiced for it so you know what to
expect 4:15 a.m. wake-up breakfast and
then they show up here in the Superdome
and so you got your suit on and you sat
down in that seat and they hook you up
these panels to make sure that
everything was working correctly before
you head it out
so all suited up now the three Apollo 11
astronauts walked down this hallway
right with the team supporting them and
the support crew here in crew quarters
would be standing at the door cheering
and clapping and they get over here and
get on the elevator to go down to get on
the Astro van and go to the pad once you
come out those doors and you see the
cameras and you see the people I got to
imagine these guys are realizing the
whole world is watching you walk out and
everybody's cheering and clapping and it
just it makes you feel proud so we were
just in the crew quarters where the crew
gets dressed right this is where correct
me if I'm wrong the rocket gets dressed
that's right the Vehicle Assembly
Building and the Saturn five is still
the biggest rocket ever made and
put that thing together you had to build
what is still one of the biggest
buildings ever made absolutely these
ceilings are 500 plus feet yeah I think
it's like 535 when you're up on the roof
we're on our way to the roof we're on
our way to the roof we're at the 34
level now and we're gonna get on a
different elevator that goes all the way
up to the top
Sao Paulo 1150 years ago 50 years ago
that pet the crawler-transporter would
pick up the mobile launcher with the
rocket on it roll out those big doors go
in less than a mile an hour and head out
that three and a half mile trek to the
pad you say 39b is our future 39b and
then we've been challenged to put the
first woman and next man on the moon in
2024 and we're gonna make that happen
I think we've got an outstanding future
and I did ask Cabana about a new CBS
poll that shows fewer than 50% of
Americans think their country remains
the world leader in space exploration he
acknowledged that NASA probably has to
do a better job communicating to the
public about what he calls the great
things they're doing but he thinks we're
still the leader and to demonstrate it
he says we'll be going back to the moon
in 2024 and then after that of course
the goal is Mars
Gale the goal is Mars Tony that was such
a great piece part of your piece we had
side by side of what they did back then
and then it showed you walking today in
2019 very nicely done
gives me a lot of goosebumps thank you
sir